lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
si podemos encontrar la medida del
ángulo de muy bien entonces vamos a
tratar de ver si podemos encontrar la
medida de este ángulo y como en cada uno
de estos vídeos te invito a que hagas
una pausa y trates de resolver este
problema por tu propia cuenta y te voy a
dar una pista va a requerir que pienses
en cómo es que este ángulo inscrito se
relaciona con la medida del arco que
sostiene así que piénsalo por ese lado y
ahorita lo resolvemos todos juntos
muy bien vamos a comenzar con lo
siguiente vamos a preguntarnos qué es lo
que realmente sabemos hasta este momento
y lo que sabemos es que este ángulo de
define a un arco que es bastante grande
verdad este arco que incluso estoy
remarcando con color verdad está
definiendo a todo este arco a todo este
arco y eso es importante porque si
supiéramos la medida de este arco
entonces nosotros podríamos calcular
fácilmente la medida de este ángulo
porque nosotros sabemos que la medida
del ángulo inscrito es igual a la mitad
de la medida del arco verdad pero en
realidad nosotros no sabemos la medida
de este arco pero si sabemos la medida
del arco
digamos que completa la circunferencia y
que de hecho voy a marcar con azul
nosotros podemos calcular la digamos
fácilmente la medida de este arco y tú
te preguntarás oye cómo podemos hacerlo
si no nos están etiquetando esa medida
bueno pues en realidad esto
lo podemos calcular porque nos dieron la
información de este ángulo inscrito que
sostiene a este arco verdad de hecho
este ángulo es de 45 grados y nosotros
sabemos que la medida del ángulo
inscrito es la mitad de la medida del
arco que sostiene o bien en la medida
del arco que sostiene es el doble de la
medida del ángulo inscrito así que la
medida de este arco lo voy a poner así
la medida del arco la medida del arco w
l este es el arco wv l su medida es el
doble de 45 grados y esos son 90 grados
muy bien y esto es bastante útil porque
si si ahora pensamos en darle toda la
vuelta a la circunferencia entonces
tendríamos 360 grados y como nos a
nosotros nos interesa este ángulo
digamos morado entonces al sumarle w
la medida del arco wv
nos debe dar 360 grados así que déjenme
ir escribiendo todo eso nosotros tenemos
que la medida del arco
wv y le tengo que poner estas tres
letras porque es el arco más grande de
verdad es el arco mayor la medida de ese
arco más la medida del arco w l
la medida del arco wv l eso debe ser
igual a 360 grados sin embargo nosotros
ya sabemos cuál es la medida del arco w
l y de hecho es de 90 grados verdad así
que si restamos 90 grados de ambos lados
vamos a obtener lo siguiente vamos a
obtener que la medida del arco w y l es
igual a 360 grados menos 90 y eso son
270 grados muy bien entonces la medida
de todo
este arco es de 270 grados muy bien y
finalmente lo que digamos lo que a
nosotros nos interesaba era calcular la
medida de este ángulo de verdad que es
el ángulo inscrito y que de hecho define
a este arco morado verdad así que la
medida de este de este digamos de este
ángulo más bien es la mitad de la medida
del arco así que este ángulo va a medir
la mitad de 270 y eso es 135 grados muy
bien entonces algo que es bastante
interesante y que podemos notar en este
ejercicio es lo siguiente qué pasa si
sumamos 135 si a 135 le sumamos 45 bueno
135 más 45 nos da 180 grados y así
parece que es en este caso verdad de
hecho parece ser que los ángulos
opuestos de un cuadrilátero inscrito son
suplementarios es decir que suman 180
grados
yo no podría preguntarse bueno sera
esto es digamos obra de este caso
particular o será que siempre van a ser
suplementarios
es decir si siempre que tenemos un
cuadrilátero inscrito en una
circunferencia de esto es que que sus
cuatro vértices se encuentren sobre la
circunferencia verdad será que siempre
que veamos dos ángulos opuestos será
cierto que su suma es 180 grados es
decir que sean suplementarios y te
invito a que lo mediten e incluso trates
de demostrarlo de hecho la demostración
es bastante parecido a lo que hicimos
aquí solo que en ese caso habría que
poner números digamos como en general
verdad en vez de poner 45 grados
habría que poner equis y a lo mejor en
vez de 135 tendríamos que llegar a que
esto vale 180 menos x verdad de todas
formas lo voy a hacer en un vídeo y
podrás ver si nuestro razonamiento es
similar